this is what we're talking about these
coefficients
okay these coefficients this is a
function of X right so I'm gonna say
well let's call that F okay now where
will I go from here well I'm gonna go to
calculus you're like calculus no don't
go to calculus calculus is not about
discrete numbers calculus is the
mathematics of continuous numbers right
which is why I like continuity and
limits are the kinds of things the way
you start calculus okay but just like
Hong Kong in London binomial theorem and
calculus are made of the same DNA watch
what can I do to this what can I do with
calculus I could differentiate it okay -
okay now it's a simple function I know
you don't know what it is but you don't
need to what's the derivative and one
plus X and minus one oh so even though
even though calculus is about continuous
numbers you can see the discrete numbers
sneaked in don't they right let's keep
going let's see if we can work out a
pattern here okay if I differentiate it
let's get a second review okay um I
repeat the process don't I okay so that
ends hanging out there but like now
multiply by the new power right so I'm
gonna get n minus 1 and the power drops
down one more time you happy with that
cool okay now here was one of the
problems with what I showed you
yesterday okay I showed you one
particular line of Pascal's triangle
this one I think it was this okay and
then we looked at the pattern and then I
generalize from there okay but that's a
really kind of dicey thing to do I want
to be able to generalize properly and
calculus lets you do that okay first
second derivative let's just do the
third one but because I don't want to
have dashes flying around everywhere
choose a subtle little extra bit of
notation which is it rather than do more
dashes I'm just going to put that number
up there in brackets I can't just make
it a three to indicate the third
derivative because if you saw F 3 X what
would you guess that means cubed right
so where to brackets that means I've
differentiated three times okay I'm
doing it three times so establish the
pattern right where you can get and n
minus 1 n minus 2 there you go power
comes down and it reduces by one okay
now I think this isn't enough to
establish well what happens if I went
some indeterminate number of times right
not one or two or three but oh I don't
know something like say R times okay
what would be dot dot dot
what would the ah derivative be hmm
well I'd refrigerated some number of
times right so I'm gonna go and and then
I'm gonna get n minus 1 n minus 2 and
they don't have to multiply some number
of times where will I end well the last
term in this product be hmm now you have
a look at the numbers right when I
differentiate it once it was n when a
differentiator twice it was n minus 1
where I ended when I differentiate 3
times it was n minus 2 where I ended
right so they all start with end they
all subtract a number what did they
subtract they subtract ah but it's not
quite is it right because this is not n
minus 3 it slowly a minus 2
I'm off by 1 so I have to add 1 to
compensate that's where I end are you
happy with that
that's my last the last how they've got
brought down okay there you go
well there's the X term that's still
there because of chain rule right what
will the new power be n minus R right
good ok now at the moment um you're
starting to think ok this is a bit sauce
right I can see some factorial business
in here quite clearly right but how do I
work with it how do I work with it
I think you can work it out right this
is not one neat factorial in here there
are two right what are they have a look
I can't just write it's n factorial at
the front because come on it doesn't go
down all the way to three two one finish
okay so I have to divide by something
don't I
what's missing off the end if I gave you
for example ten times nine times eight
you know there has to be a tenth
factorial right but of course you're
you're missing what are you missing
seven six five four cetera
right you're missing seven factorial
right whatever that next term is that
missing one you're missing all the ones
after it so what's the missing term here
it'll hear the N minus R and then n
minus R minus one in front of R minus
two all the way down to the end okay so
therefore I have this mmm suspicious
right obviously you could guess that
because you already know what this was
always going to be but you can see it
even if you didn't know if we started
here you could see it based on this kind
of logic right okay so that's all of the
stuff out the front right one plus x
okay this is the odd derivative of f
okay now hold on a second hold a second
recite for me again what what is this
what are we after that NCR the
definition was it's the it's the
coefficient of all of these terms right
all I'm really interested in is the
coefficients there's no exes here right
so what would be a neat way to get rid
of the exes in this equation I don't
know what the X is there anymore I'm
only interested in the coefficients so
what I'll do is this is the problematic
termini to flicker out of the way right
so I can choose a value of x like it's
it's a derivative it exists for and it's
um it's a polynomial right no
discontinuities just pick a value of x
any value X that'll get rid of this
and the obvious choice is zero right if
I make X equals zero this would just be
1 ^ whatever doesn't matter
okay so therefore or how do I write this
if x equals zero it would be the are
through of F at zero is that okay so to
be n factorial on n minus R factorial
times 1 to the power of that so it's
just in factorial okay now this is good
is it good right
this is astonishingly close to what I'm
after
it's not there is it I mean you wouldn't
expect it to be exactly that because um
this is not about the coefficients of
this try it's about something
differentiating so be that we are very
very close but not there what else could
we do here how do I need to how am I
going to get I have I have this pot how
do I get the rest of it into the picture
hmm
now I'm pausing here because I I can
immediately tell you and then it'll be
obvious right but this is this is the
actual valuable moment well you can
think about it not having worked out
what it is already and think okay if I
set out to prove this and this is what I
already know what's missing
that coefficients I approached this in
such a way that I got this part out
right but I didn't say anything about
these coefficients I never did right
none of this has to do with a platform
when I am put in zero to get rid of all
the X terms right none of it actually
tells you it has coefficients in it
that's why none of this notation appears
right it's the conspicuous absence from
it okay so how can I get it oh well it
comes back to F doesn't it but I know
how to write F I know how to write F
exactly in terms of the coefficients
that are defined okay what would the
first coefficient be the first I should
have said zeroeth I suppose because
it'll be into zero right in Pascal's
triangle it'll be five trees naught and
then we 5 choose 1
I'm just 2 and so on okay so I'm gonna
have the next one
in c1 what power X will there be just
one one it matches actually what your um
r-value is and then you get the next one
and that's three I think that's enough
where do I end again and n right and of
course your last value of x the big ok
cool
hmm now I looked at this thing F and
then I did these processes to it right
and here's where I arrived now I've got
the same thing but I'm looking at it
from a different angle right I'm looking
at the same object I am looking at the
same object right but I want to be able
to compare this thing this is where I
ended up right so I'm going to take the
same object then I'm gonna apply exactly
the same processes to it and in theory
if I can get to an expression for this
then whatever I end with here should be
equal to that right if I do all the same
things to it okay so what I do I
differentiate it first didn't I okay
what's F - what happens to it what
happens to that MC 0 front disappears
your skip NC 1 right actually you get
one x NZ one why is that why is there
one there because it's because of this
power isn't it I know we're not used to
writing it but it's gonna be helpful for
us right what happens to this guy the
two comes out the front and then he
loses one of his powers for you and I
don't have a Hugh but you can guess what
the next one will be right what should I
write it would have been a cubed terms
so be three and three right and now
that's going to be next Quintin there's
the three x squared in minute the
derivatives see that where do I end I
mean in at the front and CN whoops sorry
brackets throw away and the power of
this will be struck down one half of it
just like this drop down one so so this
line here is the expansion of this line
so make sense okay what did I do then I
differentiate it again we try to work
out a pattern here
right so second derivative okay what
happens to the first term it disappears
it's a constant what happens to the next
term
well it'll be 2 times 1 right nc2 and
then that X disappears okay what happens
to this guy
well he'll become 3 times 2 and then
this power drops down by 1 you don't
have it there but you can guess what the
next term will be right it used to be an
X to the 4 term out here then it became
an X cubed term here so now be next
squared term here it'd be 4 by 3 by 2
it'll be NC 4 and now be an x squared
what are the last ten day it comes from
this guy so BM Rena power down and
reduce should I want okay now I know
before we went to three I wonder if you
can see the pattern by now okay what
will happen if I do this dot dot dot R
times what will happen well a whole
bunch of these guys at the front will
disappear
boy they the more times you
differentiate the more terms you get rid
of okay until eventually your first term
will be a constant what constant will it
be numbers match up well with our first
derivative right what I had here was a 1
actually I had a 1 factorial didn't I
right when I differentiate it twice I
had 2 times 1 I had um I had 2 factorial
right so by the time I've done this R
times what would you guess is out the
front that's gonna be our factorial
right and then there's going to be that
coefficient wherever it started which
coefficient will it be it'll be the
earth coefficient NCR right you can see
the numbers match up right this is why I
was so important to put one there okay
now that's the constant term now this is
interesting you'll get a whole bunch of
terms after this okay but I'm actually
not interested in what they are I'm only
interested in the fact that they're all
going to have a common factor of X now
you can go ahead and work out what
actually belongs in here okay but all I
want to know is that they all have X's
in them why would this be significant
that they will have at least one
excellent aha
because immediately after this I got to
here and then I said but I don't want
any of the x's and so we did this right
and it cleared out all the x's just like
it's going to do here right so let's do
that
let's substitute in x equals 0 whatever
these guys are they all collapse
okay they all disappear so now I'm left
with this at x equals zero the after
rivet --iv from this angle from from
this angle right the expansion angle
right rather than the chain rule angle
that's how I approach it on that side
apparently it's going to be this can you
finish it for me I said we should end up
at the same spot good this derivative at
zero and we've got this derivative at
zero it should be the same right so I've
got sorry R factorial front times that
coefficient that's left over after all
the differentiating that's equal to n
factorial on n minus R factorial so all
you need to do is divide and that's
freaking badass I think now like I said
like I said discrete numbers really why
calculus well I calculate now you can
see some of the reasons why actually
it's a very clever very very very clever
way to go about it